this morning we continue our special
series kindness 101 with steve hartman
sharing stories that are built around
themes of kindness and character and the
people who have mastered those qualities
this morning's lesson is redemption
steven his kids show us how messing up
and having everything to lose showed one
man what he had to gain
good morning welcome to class this is my
daughter meryl and today we're going to
discuss
redemption
to find out what it means let's go over
to your brother emmett at the dictionary
desk emmett so redemption has a rather
simple definition it's basically just a
second chance yeah it could mean making
up for a mistake
when i was a kid
i stole something from a store
and for years it bothered me
so as an adult
i wrote a letter to the company and sent
him money for what i'd stolen
i was seeking redemption
you've done so many other great things
in your life thank you you're welcome
but you know i once did a story about a
guy who did something much worse but did
something much greater to redeem himself
so let's turn now to my archive of real
life life lessons and pull off the shelf
a dramatic tale
of redemption
take you down to my old neighborhood for
31 year old jermaine wilson of
leavenworth kansas going back to his
childhood is a bad trip yeah i used to
see a lot of drugs out here right there
in apartment 4. he started using at age
11. was in juvenile detention by 15 and
in the maximum security wing at lansing
correctional by 21 and it was here that
this convicted drug dealer came to the
most important realization of his life
if i don't change it's either going to
be two things that's going to happen i'm
either going to spend the rest of my
life in prison or dead in a casket you
could have never imagined the third
option no not at all
we want to welcome you to our city
commission meeting jermaine became the
mayor of leavenworth kansas motion
carried 5-0 it's a transformation he
credits to god education and volunteer
work after prison he became a community
activist and got his felony record
expunged paving the way for a political
run a lot of politicians decide to run
for office and then go to prison
you're doing it the other way around
what are the advantages there's this
quote that i always go by you'll never
know what you are until you've
encountered what you are not i
experienced being someone that i wasn't
created to be and when i tried the
opposite i succeeded you can be what you
want to be yes i can today jermaine
couldn't be more opposite the school
district that once had him expelled now
welcomes him back with open arms
i'm the community outreach coordinator
he also works for a non-profit that
helps ex-cons find and keep good jobs
that's good and of course he has his
mayoring duties all made possible he
says by the gift of incarceration that's
why i'm here because if that wouldn't
happen i would have never had the time
to think i would have never had an
opportunity you know to build a
relationship with god
so you suggest prison no i don't suggest
prison
but one thing i tell you we all go
through a time in our life
where we hit rock bottom when you're at
rock bottom there's only one other place
to go
and that's uh
beating adjourn
jermaine wilson joins us now hello
jermaine how you doing sir we're doing
great are you still mayor
i'm currently serving as the mayor pro
10 i'll serve as the mayor next year i
just actually uh won my re-election
what was the first step in your path to
redemption
first off i had to recognize that you
know that i had some issues i had to
change up my mindset i started writing
out things that i wanted to accomplish
in my life i was telling the kids
earlier about a time when i stole
something and years later paid the money
that i owed the store
and it felt like a weight was lifted off
my shoulder
did you have that same feeling when you
finally had redemption
uh yes and i i feel it every day uh
because
your heart has changed your mindset has
changed do you want to be president
someday
no ma'am i just want to continue to
serve my community what about any higher
office at this particular time i have no
desire for any higher office that's what
politicians say when they are going to
vote for higher office
i've heard it said many times jermaine i
don't know
were you always this joyful or is this a
byproduct of your redemption
back then you know always like making
people laugh but it was doing it in the
wrong way
now i have everlasting joy and peace
we can see that on you thank you so much
for joining us jermaine thank you mr
steve hartley
jermaine says you never know what you
are until you've encountered what you
are not and if you've ever felt guilty
about something that is you encountering
what you are not and it's important to
listen to that feeling
that's what i hope you guys take from
this
and you too
we'll see you next time until then stay
kind
every every week jamie i go that's my
favorite one that's my favorite one he
does something like that and now this is
your favorite yes jermaine wilson with
that megawatt smile yes oh my god
i love that he's the mayor and then
re-election i do too
i love too when steve was talking about
stealing something meryl was looking up
like you did that dad
and i like ramirez says he does not
recommend going to prison yeah let's all
avoid that i think that's a good idea
that's good advice we'll be right back